david quelles sont les recommandations
pour astrazeneca et bien durant la
conférence de presse cet après midi le
président de la haute autorité à 2 santé
a affirmé que le vaccin astrazeneca
représente une performance entre 62 et
70 % assez satisfaisant pour sa mise sur
le marché français il devient donc le
troisième vaccin être autorisées et sur
notre territoire
en revanche comme on pouvait s y
attendre son administration n'est pas
recommandé aux plus de 65 ans mis en
cause en allemagne notamment son
efficacité ne serait que de 8 % chez les
personnes de plus de 65 ans est les
données manquent encore pour le moment
la haute autorité de santé recommande
donc de vacciner tous les professionnels
la médicale ainsi que les personnes
allant de 50 à 65 ans présentant la des
risques
autre point important il pourra être
administrée par les pharmaciens et les
sages-femmes en plus des infirmiers et
des médecins a noté qui peut être stocké
à long terme dans des frigos classique
ce qui facilite son déploiement
logistique par rapport aux deux autres
max est la mise sur le marché david de
ce vaccin va t'elle régler la pénurie
qui existe actuellement
et bien malheureusement non puisque
avant d'ouvrir ce nouveau canal d'accès
à la vaccination il faudra disposer de
suffisamment de doses et la livraison ne
se fera pas tout de suite
l a france tablait mardi dernier sur
seulement 4,6 millions de doses soit 29%
de commandes promises d'ici fin mars les
livraisons arrivent dans arriveront donc
au compte goutte une solution naturelle
se présentent au gouvernement français
c'est le vaccin aux russes efficace à
91,6 % selon une étude de la revue
médicale the lands est validée par des
experts indépendants du côté de
l'allemagne il est déjà le bienvenu
selon les mots d'angela merkel si l'
agence européenne du médicament est le
valier d'écouté est d'ailleurs à ce
propos le leader de la france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon va se faire
les allemands ont décidé donc ça sera
le président français n'a plus aucune
autorité dans ce domaine je préfère
aussi d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
rappeler que les russes en début de
crise on proposer aux français une co
production de vaccins et que ensuite ils
ont été le proposer aux argentins tout
suivre ces questions en s'intéressant à
ce que font les autres gouvernements et
pas en restant dans ce nombrilisme aiguë
dans lequel sont les autorités
françaises qui contre toute raison se
targue d'avoir fait des réussites de
tout cela il y un vaccin russe qui
fonctionne il y aura il ya un vaccin
français qui arrivent sur le marché dont
il faut que tout
toutes ces possibilités sont explorées
par l'union européenne mais j'ai vu que
madame merkel qui est plus réaliste
monsieur macron a pris langue avec le
monsieur cloutier pour traiter de cette
histoire de va bien donc je suppose que
tous les autres vont se mettre au garde
à vous maintenant et bombe a coûté 6 et
madame merkel qui fument les
revendications mieux que monsieur mâcon
je n'y vois pas d'inconvénient
même son de cloche pour marine le pen
sur twitter la présidente du
rassemblement national interpelle le
gouvernement sur l'efficacité du
spoutnik vl demande de travailler en
bonne intelligence avec la russie et ne
pas laisser l'idéologie ruiner nos
capacités à vacciner nos compatriotes
voilà en tout cas les quarts sont
totalement rebattues avec cette annonce
du dieu de la revue de 2,2 hollande 7
médical et le gouvernement va peut-être
devoir changer de fusil d'épaulé dans sa
stratégie de vaccination
merci david qualif en direct de la haute
autorité de santé